el photo tropismo en las plantas es una
respuesta en la que el brote de la
planta crece hacia una fuente de luz los
resultados de cinco tratamientos
experimentales distintos de las
investigaciones clásicas de photo
tropismo se muestran arriba inciso a
apoya la afirmación de que las células
situadas en el ápice del brote de la
planta detectan la luz mediante la
comparación de los resultados del grupo
de tratamiento 1 con los resultados del
grupo de tratamiento 2 y el grupo de
tratamiento 3
así que queremos comparar estos tres
primeros grupos de tratamiento y se
puede ver que cuando se tiene el ápice
sin alteraciones la planta completa se
va a doblar en dirección a la luz cuando
se corta el ápice ya no se inclina en la
dirección de la luz o si se cubre el
ápice con algún tipo de tapa opaca de
manera que la luz no pueda pasar a
través de ella tampoco se va a doblar
hacia la luz así que esta es una muy
buena evidencia de que existe algo en el
ápice de la planta que permite que el
foto tropismo ocurra le permite a la
planta saber en qué dirección se
encuentra la luz y luego de alguna
manera hace que la planta se doble en
esa dirección así que podemos escribir
que el foto tropismo
sólo ocurrió
cuando el ápice
de la planta
estaba inalterado
y tenía acceso a la luz
eso ocurrió en el tratamiento 1
la planta
no sé doblado
cuando se cortó
el ápice
eso fue en el tratamiento 2
ni cuando el lápiz
tenía una cubierta
o para qué
eso fue en el tratamiento 3
así que eso es todo lo que hay que hacer
solo ocurrió cuando el lápiz estaba
inalterado y tenía acceso a la luz la
planta no se dobló cuando se cortó el
ápice eso fue en el tratamiento 2 ni en
el tratamiento 3 por lo que es un muy
buen indicativo de que se necesita el
ápice y necesita tener acceso a la luz
hay algo en el ápice que permite que la
planta sepa en qué dirección se debe
doblar
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer el inciso b
en los grupos de tratamiento 4 y 5 son
estos dos grupos de tratamiento los
ápices de las plantas son removidos y
colocados de nuevo en el brote en una
barrera permeable o en una barrera
impermeable utilizando los resultados de
los grupos de tratamiento 4 y 5 describe
dos características adicionales de la
respuesta fotográfica pues bien cuando
el lápiz es colocado encima de una
barrera permeable el foto tropismo
todavía ocurre la planta aún se dobla
así que a pesar de que el lápiz está
desconectado debido a que esta barrera
es permeable el ápice debe de poder
detectar la luz y liberar algún tipo de
sustancia hormonal o química que es
capaz de atravesar esta barrera
permeable y de alguna manera mandar
señales al resto de la planta para que
se doble en la dirección correcta porque
cuando se coloca una barrera impermeable
el ápice podría estar tratando de
liberar esas mismas sustancias pero no
pueden atravesar la barrera
por lo que el resto de la planta no sabe
que debe doblarse o en qué dirección
debe hacerlo así que podríamos decir que
el ápice
debe deliberar
algún tipo
de sustancia
hormonal
o química' que señala
al resto de la planta
que se doble
y en qué dirección
hacerlo
sabemos esto
de vida
aquí
de los tratamientos
4 y 5
solo el tratamiento 4
en el que la barrera
es permeable
a esa sustancia
muestra
foto tropiece ma
y el tratamiento 5
no lo muestra
esa es la única explicación aquí ya que
no lo está haciendo de alguna manera a
través de ondas de radio o sustancias
que se liberan en el aire y flotan hacia
el resto de la planta de alguna manera
algún tipo de sustancia está pasando
desde el ápice de la planta hacia el
resto de la planta y cuando se bloquea
ya no es capaz de enviar esas señales
químicas esa es la mejor explicación que
se me ocurre para el comportamiento que
vemos entre los tratamientos 4 y 5